now well let's head into the weekend on
a good note first friday is back and
better than ever
nearly at full capacity thank you for
joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez so this marked the
second time the event was in person
since kobe shut everything down
but as sasha loftus explains this time
there were a lot more people around hi
there sasha
good evening denise first friday is
certainly a blast we are all glad to
have events
like this back in our lives but it
really just offers so much more than
that
the businesses and vendors we spoke with
say they really are glad to have this
opportunity
to bounce back
the sound of music the sight of people
laughing
and the smell of good food is what we've
all been waiting for you hear everyone
talking about vegas coming back but
first friday is where you actually see
it
for the second month in a row first
friday is making a comeback downtown
after a year of coven 19 shutdowns
i think it's a very nice addition to
come back after
what it's been a long time man hundreds
were thrilled to return to the beloved
event
but the biggest benefit its boost to
local business
it was just amazing to see the crowd
welcome us back
sarah bolden of blazing food chariot
says the last few months have been tough
and her team is grateful for this
opportunity
every road you go to you couldn't work
you couldn't do anything
so it was really hard in fact first
friday executive director corey fagan
says
every single vendor here is thankful for
so much
local loyalty the community really came
out and showed their support and
and really helped to stimulate their
economic growth
as for those who came out they called it
a great way to
celebrate the fun our city can finally
offer again it's really a nice thing to
see and
you know re-engage with everyone that
we've been missing out on for the last
year
now covid regulations were of course in
place tonight that included mask
requirements
temperature checks and those capacity
limits here on
the grounds of first friday we did speak
to a couple other
other vendors tonight who said they
actually saw more business tonight
than they did in april reporting live
downtown tonight sasha loftis
8 news now